des délégués en extase à la COP15 alors
que la partie de soccer de la Coupe du
monde entre la Croatie et le Brésil bat
son plein
juste à côté d'autres tirent la sonnette
d'alarme pour éviter que les
négociateurs à la conférence à cause
d'une
sourisant à la conférence qui
considèrent que les négociations
traînent
qui insiste sur l'importance d'intégrer
les autochtones dans le processus
décisionnel sans quoi elle craint que
leurs droits soit ignorés un accord qui
va avoir un mécanisme ou les peuples
autochtones ne sont pas considérés comme
parti prenante mais comme les
participants qui ont les droits de
discuter des négocier
notre territoire à notre façon
même discours de ce représentant de la
communauté du Lac Simon en abitibie
Ronald brazzo réclame que son territoire
devienne une ère protégée avant que
l'industrie minière et forestière
étendent leur
tentaculesations c'est de voir son
territoire pillés de même si saccagé de
virer tout en travers une aire protégée
dans laquelle son peuple sera souverain
et pourra exploiter durablement les
ressources pour ainsi préserver leur
identité zoo de la forêt c'est notre
maison c'est là qu'on prend toute la
ressources le Canada pays au de la
conférence dit vouloir jouer son rôle de
leader pour faire avancer les choses
l'une des choses que je vais faire au
cours des prochains jours c'est de
chercher insuffler un certain sens
d'urgence et je suis pas le seul pour
que les négociateurs accélèrent le port
les négociateurs dans les corridors que
les choses avancent lentement mais
sûrement mais que l'on dilue la portée
des ambitions pour arriver à une
conclusion ici Elisa serrer Radio-Canada
Montréal